[Music]
that's
hi
[Music]
h
Christian
[Music]
and I was like
my
[Music]
as the timer went down that was really
nice if only that happened in my
classroom when I was a
teacher never
uh well welcome everyone um lots of new
faces for me here I feel like I say that
every time I'm up here which is a great
thing right that means new people are
coming and new people are visiting and
continuing to come so if I have not met
you my name is miam nice to see you all
uh I will be happy to meet you after
service um and thank you for coming to
church even though the Cowboys are
playing I see a couple Jersey so woo go
Cowboys not going to spoil it but
they're winning Soo
W I'm just y I'm kidding I don't know I
don't know I don't know I really I'm
truly I truly I don't know all right so
I don't know I really don't know ask
Google I don't know um all right couple
of announcements for us so it's the
first Sunday of the month um so that
means hat Creek right so if you are not
familiar first Sunday of every month we
meet as a a group as a community at hat
Creek um I don't and I'm not I don't
live here does anyone remember like the
the address
area there you go right there or just
type it into Google
Maps it has a hat on it she says so look
for the Hat all right uh next week um we
are doing baptisms next Sunday so in
order to prepare for that right after
service um in this area Brett is going
to be holding a baptism class feel free
to attend that you attending does not
mean that you have to get baptized or
that it's you know mandatory for you to
do so if if you're just wanting to learn
more about baptisms in general or how
they're performed here Brett is happy to
um sit with you and walk you through
that so feel free to jump in on that um
and again next Sunday will be baptisms
in the service so that'll be a good time
um and then the last one is we have a
workshop on Thursday the 25th from 7 to
9: it's here and that is becoming a
better Ally so if you are interested in
attending that it is free but
registration is required so please scan
that QR code for uh registration um but
that's it for announcement so as we um
move into worship I uh as some of y'all
might know I'm very much a uh a thinker
I think on a lot of things and I Ponder
on a lot of things and what I have kind
of been sitting with this week is the
idea of O maybe overanalyzing things or
thinking too much about things which I
think you know it's it's funny to think
about that way but um just a little
backstory I was at the gym the other day
and I dropped a weight on my phone and I
thought it was great and dandy and then
I went to FaceTime my girlfriend that
that night and my front camera doesn't
work so being in a longdistance
relationship you can see Ah that's kind
of sucks right kind of sucks went to the
store $600 to fix so the point of this
is is I have been for since yesterday
that's all I can think about that's all
I can think about is I got to get my
phone fixed I'm so upset I I did this
and is it not true that most people will
sacrifice what they most want for what
they want now right and that doesn't
have to be a tangible thing and to me
now is the most expensive word in the
dictionary I have sacrificed so much
time today thinking about something I
want now I want my phone fixed now but
in the grand scheme of things I feel
like I've always Ed all day with my
thoughts and things I could have been
doing my phone's still not fixed right I
it's not like I did anything and I think
that's very interesting it's something
to sit on right what are you what are
you putting your thoughts into what are
you putting your um your actions into
does it really matter in the grand
scheme of things could you be doing
something else with that so as we go
into worship um I'm going to lead us in
a prayer that I hope will stand true for
all of us as we sit through through this
story Sunday today so God thank you so
much for the safety and everyone getting
here tonight not only those here in
person but those
online I pray that as I had mentioned
before that if we have anything on our
minds you know anything as small as a
phone being broken or something massive
maybe job loss or whatever the case may
be we're all going through something to
whatever extent that may be I pray that
you lift those worries those thoughts
that angst
those fears and you just have everyone
sit here knowing that they're loved by
the people around them and knowing that
they're here for a
reason I pray that you lift those
burdens from their minds and their
hearts and I pray that they're able to
take something out of these stories that
we're about to hear this Sunday and I
pray for all those speaking this uh
tonight that you use
them you you speak your truth and your
word through them for us to hear and I
pray this all in Jesus name
amen
thanks um if you guys want to stand with
us we're going to get started with our
music and kind of um a theme that you
might pick up on as we're going through
the set tonight is just this idea that
um God is doing a good work in us and um
he's on our side um I love I love um
remembering that
what I'm experiencing right now is not
the full picture not the full story of
what God is doing and what he's at work
um on in me in my family in our
communities um it's just a very small
fraction of the whole and when I can get
that perspective and know that there's a
good work going on and and whenever I
can kind of lean into that work and
invite him in believe that there's
something good um that he is for me that
he is not just focused on my mistakes
and my failures but he is believing for
something better it allows me to have
some hope for today for tomorrow um so I
hope that you guys can resonate with
that same hope as we sing together
tonight um our first song Is Your Love
defends me so you guys join in as you're
able
to You Are My
Joy you are are my
song you are the
whale the one I'm drawing from you are
my
refuge the whole night
long where else would I
go surely my God is the strength of My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defend defends me and when I feel like
I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends
me day after day
night after
night I will
remember you're with me in this fight
although the
battle eres on the
war one oh I know the
war
many surely my God is the strength of my
My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me and when I
feel I'm all
alone yeah you love TOS Me Your Love
defends me and we sing
her
name you're my portion
my
salvation we
[Music]
sing you're my
portion my salvation one more
time
huj you're my
portion my
salvation
huah surely my God is the strength My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me and when I feel like I'm all
alone love defends Me Your Love defends
me surely my God strength of My
Soul Your Love defends
me when
I I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me and we
singu you're my my
portion my
[Music]
salvu you're my
portion my sound let's just sing that
out
halelu you're my
portion my
salvation
all right you kids are dismissed to go
to your
[Music]
classrooms thank you guys for joining us
for that first
[Music]
song and thank you kids ministry
volunteers and teachers and workers
thanks so much for loving on our kids
hey
[Music]
Bellamy
we're going to go ahead and transition
into um what we call prayers of the
people and if you haven't been with us
before this is just a portion during our
service where we like to offer up the
things that we're carrying into this
space together just name them and hold
them up before God and each other and
allow other people to kind of shoulder
that burden with us if you will um so
let's read through this prayer together
and then will leave space for you to say
the name or situation that you might be
carrying on your heart tonight and then
we'll end together together again with
the rest of the prayer read this with me
please for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and dis I'm sorry guys I I
skipped a line for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race and
other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to
you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray that you
may that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen
your known and
by I breath when I doubt it Lord
remind I'm wonderfully made you're an
artist and a pot I'm the canvas and the
clay you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
[Music]
glory and for your name
there's just
beond
through I see clear now I know nothing
has been
wasted
you're an AR
in
the to make all
things work
together for my
future and for my cour you make all
things work
together for your
glory
and for your name you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name
[Music]
when I doubt it Lord
remind I'm wonderfully made you're an
artist and a and the canvas and the CL I
know nothing has been wasted no failure
you're an artist and a I'm the
canas we're not doubt it Lord remind me
I'm wonderfully made you're an artist
and a I'm the can the CL I know nothing
has been wasted no failure are mistakes
you're an artist and a Potter the can
and the clay you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name when I doubt it
Lord remind me I'm wonderfully made
you're an artist and a Potter I'm the
can the clay I know nothing has been
wasted no failure our mistakes you're an
artist and a Potter I'm the can the clay
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me yet you're not finished
with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me yet you're not finished
with me yet you're not finished with me
yet you're not finished with me you're
not finished with me
yet
[Music]
will
build your
love is firm
found and I will put my TR in you
alone and I will not be
shy
of could
[Music]
singy of all the praise we could ever
bring Worthy every breath we could ever
Brea we live for
[Music]
you
Jesus Jesus the name above every
name Jesus the only one who could
ever worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for you
we live for
you and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and F me
with your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
To those of around
[Music]
me worthy of every song we could ever
sing worthy of all the praise we could
ever
breing worthy of every breath we could
ever breae we live for
you we live for
[Music]
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could
ever worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for
you
we live
you and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes
in and show me who you are and fail me
with your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
to those around me and
there is no one like you there isone
beside you open up my
eyes show me who you are and fill me
with your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
to those around
[Music]
me
and I will build my life upon your love
it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone and I will not be
Shen and I will build my life upon your
love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone I will not be sing Holy and
holy there is no one
like you there isone beside you open up
my eyes and wonder and show me who you
are and fill me with your heart and Lead
Me In Your Love to
those around
me God I do ask that Your Love would
fill us up so much that it
overflows into our homes into the places
that we work that we
learn into our
families and our
relationships God I ask in the same way
that you have not given up on us and
that you're not finished with us you're
still doing a good work would we believe
that for
ourselves and for each
other would we hang on to that
Foundation that Firm Foundation of your
love your
forgiveness and would you make us
[Music]
whole help us to build our lives on
you and to carry it with us into every
place that we
go in Jesus name
amen thank you guys so much much y'all
can go ahead and have a seat and as you
do would you just welcome the people
around you make them feel at home and
then uh Brett will get us started with
the next part of our
service
well Grace and peace um it's so good to
be with you all my name is Brett and uh
yeah it's a joy a joy to be with you in
this new year and um and just to yeah
extend the welcome of Christ to you um
and as always that includes those
joining us online um love youall lots
and especially anyone here tonight who
is new um we know just what it can be
like to walk through those doors for the
first time and that can just it can just
be a lot um so um yeah thank you so much
for for being among us tonight um you
know it is a new year and so we've got a
lot of um we always kind of start the
with some I don't know what to call them
special special Sundays I don't know
it's just unique Sundays where um like
tonight is story Sunday and then next
week is baptism Sunday and uh then a few
weeks later we will be transitioning to
our new um a new building a new space
that we're going to be renting um I
think many of you know this you got the
text in the email if you're on our list
you got it if you didn't you're like
what are you talking about you should
get on our list I maybe that's just a
pastor saying you should um if you you
know but if you want at the end you can
you know scan the QR code and kind of
get in the loop on these sorts of things
but um we are so it's we're not going
far anything it's we're going to be
shifting to basically the other
Methodist Church in saxi which was our
first choice because it's so close and
that of course there's always the
concern for a you know a community
without a permanent home is like oh my
gosh where are we gonna go and be you
know so it was um yeah we're so so
grateful and very excited um it's a
great yeah a great thing and as you can
see certain Sundays it starts to get
pretty full and we got the kiddos here
and the kiddos there and it's just it's
a yeah a tight space so um at any rate
we'll be kind of making that transition
that'll be the first Sunday in February
February 4th um so you can stay in the
loop um on that we'll we'll keep you in
the loop um so tonight like I mentioned
is story Sunday and uh we have you know
a real value here at the table for um
for tracking people stories and I think
some of that comes from maybe one way to
frame it is to think of like a uh kind
of a a destination versus a journey
mindset is sort of one metaphor that
that people use at times so the idea of
like you know um a destination mindset
tends to be like kind of the idea of
arriving you know sometimes it can be a
very strong emphasis on like getting
saved you know so everything is about
getting saved and the stories of course
would be about people who got saved and
their story getting sa you know um and
by the way I'm not saying that's like
bad to you I don't know people to be
saved we're about that at the table but
it's it's an but what that can get to is
sort of a destination mindset you know
so it's about arriving and then and what
do you do once you're saved well you're
just feel good that you're saved and you
know um instead of kind of a a journey
mindset which says we're just we're
growing we're growing into the image of
Christ we're we're constantly
discovering new depths of what it means
to fall in love with God to to become
more yielded to to find those parts of
our heart and Minds that are like kind
of broken or or hurting to find them
slowly healed and transformed so tonight
um we'll be just folks sharing you know
their story where they are on the
journey which means it's probably not
always like you know some neat tidy
ending um it's often it's somewhat messy
and you know we're all like in process
on the journey um but I do hope you can
kind of I don't know find yourself in
their story um that God like I don't
know brings some encouragement um to you
as they as they share so um without
further ad do I want to bring up Rachel
and Gage Kell can you all give them a
hand as they come
[Applause]
forward all
right you can sit in the middle the the
honored position you're good um so I'm
really excited actually both we have um
two couples kind of sharing tonight both
are fairly new to the table so um rachal
engag maybe you could start off sharing
just you know background like who who
are you what were those formative years
you know like as you were kind of
growing up and um if kind of Faith was
like a part of that what you know what
did that look like what was that kind of
background um so kind of bring us into
the loop on kind of who you are and and
things of that nature so yeah so uh we
moved to
Garland seven months ago now and um yeah
so like just a brief background for me
was like 10 years ago uh I was like felt
this like calling in the ministry is
like the lingo we used where I felt like
God wanted me to be a pastor and
um my parents were both atheists uh
adamantly and
so I was like really processing through
like what does that mean for me
um and I'm very
all of it was rooted in like the non
denam like mega church background and so
um I I would say that's like my my
primary background I I was thinking
critically about things but I was also
really excited about like all the themes
which is funny that like a 14-year-old
is like ah like Grace and honor and
fatherhood and I'm about these things um
yeah yeah oh and also we've been married
for three and a half years we met at
Dallas Baptist University which is funny
but um so uh for me I um if you look at
me 10 years ago I am the daughter of a
Southern Baptist pastor um and so um but
I grew up with really wonderful loving
parents my my parents are really kind
wonderful people um they're not
affirming and and the church I grew up
in was not affirming um but do well on
lots of other fronts um and so um for me
10 years ago I was a you know know the
classic church girl no cursing no
drinking very modest you know all those
things the IDE we were worried yes I
know you were um just like the ideal
Church kid for sure but was also
battling um some pretty severe mental
health issues I have diagnosed obsessive
compulsive disorder um and so that makes
things difficult sometimes um and other
mental health things uh that made it
really difficult but I really wanted to
know and love Jesus but since I as a kid
it's been really difficult for me
because the love that I was shown at
home was not always reflected in the
doctrine of the the Baptist Church I
felt like and so I I remember as a kid
asking my dad like hey why can't we let
people be gay what's the what's the why
aren't we allowing this like I feel like
Jesus would be on board with this and
always getting you know a kind response
of like you know this just isn't what's
in the Bible but it's always bothered me
since I was a kid so that's kind of my
faith
background So eventually I mean you can
kind of even here and the ending there
of certain things started to shift for
yall like when did that happen was it
kind of a a moment was it sort of the
accumulation of things over time where
you know maybe little moments like you
just described like what what was it
that started to to shift you into you
know kind of call it what you want kind
of deconstruction or or some sort of
process where you begin to question
things for me um I think it really I
think I couldn't sit with
the um I don't know what word to use
like dissonance that I felt with the
Jesus that I knew and then what I saw
other people representing Christ as I
think beginning with like the 2016
election um I was a senior in high
school and was like these people who
taught my Sunday School classes are
being super hateful on Facebook right
now I don't like that um and so that
kind of started the seeds for it for me
but then I went to DBU um and you know
you just kind of have to be like a l you
know I was just a little Progressive um
in certain things um but you know like
Diet Progressive um and uh women could
talk yeah I was like oh women should be
allowed to speak sometimes and so so I
was like a little Progressive but it
wasn't it wasn't enough and then in 2020
you know another pivotal year um seeing
George Floyd killed and the way that the
church responded was heartbreaking to me
um and uh so for me it just it kind of
set me on this like three and a half
year spiral of being like I don't even
know if God is real because we cannot be
talking about the same God if the
hateful things that these people that I
grew up with were posting um I I just
felt like okay then there must be no God
which makes things a little difficult
when you're the daughter of a pastor and
also married to someone who wants to be
a pastor so uh wrestled with that that
for a while
but yeah mine was um I would say your
story is one of like compassion and love
mine was very
like mental and intellectual where um
over time there were just like pieces
and I did like all the the church things
you know like I was kind of like a
success story for the church was like
this guy comes from like a bunch of
atheist and like he he gets it and so
like um and
so you know it it starts with my mom
becoming a Christian she became a
Christian when I was in high school and
but she was not interested in being at
church um just like with her past and
she's like a single adult um she had a
lot of difficulty like
reconciling if I have have experienced
these things what will these people
treat me like I think that's I'd say
that's the first Domino that falls and
then um I get to Bible College and
you know we're reading scripture
together and I would just have questions
about things and thought everybody else
was on the same page as me being like
hey what's going on with this right and
like just being met with like kind of
animosity and then
um in college I was part of organization
that had a lot of um guys in it who I
mean just like the the verbage we would
use is like they struggled with samex
attraction and um
there was
no questioning whether like what we
believed on that and there were a lot of
like really close friendships with those
guys um who were you know I remember one
of my friends telling me like his whole
faith for 18 years had just been about
not being
gay and I remember I think I was a
junior in college and I think that was
like the real first nail in the coffin
where I was like
man what are we doing here like
what what does it say about God if this
is
true and um but I kept it to myself like
I kept that thought pattern because my
thought was like who am I going to share
this with like I can't even ask like
what do we think about Genesis one guys
there's like something weird that
happens right here without kind of being
like outcasted a little bit and I think
like there was there was a lot of
heartbreak there about like uh my
relationship with the church being very
like I've done the right things I've
said all the right things I'm like
friends with the right people I'm here
every weekend serving for three
services and I can't ask a question and
um I think over time uh you know 2020
hits
um George Floyd is killed I'm reading
like a lot of um alternative I guess
theology books where it's like uh James
con and you know not white Evangelical
theologians and I start feeling like
comfort that other people think like I
do I'm not just crazy and um I think
that is really what led me to being
here was so so there youall are you're
kind of asking these questions it's
creating that
dissonance
um how was it kind of like maybe
thinking of like some of your lowest
moments like are most challenging in
terms of you're walking that out maybe
relationships in your life you know that
you really valued all of a sudden
there's like tension could you maybe
just talk for a minute about maybe a low
moment or two where it's just sort of
like you you know there's I don't know
consequences to this to these questions
to this journey yeah well mine is like
very coded in loneliness where like I
felt like all of a sudden I couldn't
talk to my friends about things and um
or or like my my dad specifically um I
mean even like in our marriage it was
like Rachel's dealing with something
that is very like heartwrenching
specifically because like it's also
about your background and your
hometown um and so it was a little bit
like we're both struggling with this but
we're struggling with it for
different like from different angles and
so I I did not personally have a hard
time with God um I had a hard time with
like the institution of church and
really resonating with a lot of people
who who've been frustrated for ever I
guess
um especially knowing like the history
of our country and our church here and I
was meeting uh Christians from other
countries who were like yeah American
Christians are kind of crazy I was like
awesome like maybe I should move to like
India I guess
like um for me I think it really like I
said began in that year of 2020 um we
were supposed to get married in April of
2020 which is super fun um and so we had
to cancel our wedding and so I was super
devastated but then on top of that there
was a lot of political unrest of course
in the world and Gage and I were very
clearly on one side and it felt like
everyone I knew who was a Christian was
somewhere else and so I was devastated
at that um and you know also dealing
with OCD it's not a fun time to be in a
pandemic um and so all these things I
felt like God couldn't be here couldn't
be present and so it it culminated in me
attempting to take my life in June of
2020 um and thankfully that didn't take
and I'm so grateful to God for that um
but that was a really low Point um a
really dark time and it again it sent me
on like a three and a half year spiral
of being like I don't think God's real I
can't I can't have anything to do with
this
um how so there you are in kind of those
low moments what what was the process to
I don't know if it was you know more
recent or farther back that you you
started to I don't know find a path
forward or sense some Grace from God in
the midst of it and in other words kind
of catch us up a little bit to today and
and where you you are today without
feeling necessarily to put a bow on it
you like and now everything's perfect
but just you know where where are you um
how would you describe it and how'd you
get here so we after that you know it
was during the pandemic that first year
we didn't really I mean we went to
church some there was a different Church
in the area we didn't go to um my dad's
church we just went to a different
church but it was very easy to just not
go to church because nobody was keeping
track um and so we tried that then we
moved to the Fort Worth area uh went to
a church there for a while but I just
always again felt it in my soul like
something is not right for me like in my
relationship with God I cannot I can't
connect with this version of God that so
many people seem to be content with who
is not inclusive and you know for
background I'm a special education
teacher and so and I've known I've
wanted to do that since I was 11 years
old and so inclusivity is the biggest
part of my life it's one of the most
important things to me and so since I
was a kid I've been like we're not
including everybody not everybody's
welcome here and so going to a church
any church felt really uncomfortable and
so finally when we moved to Garland we
were planning on going to another church
in the area but we we moved here and I
was like I can't do it anymore I have to
be affirming I can't like my my stomach
hurts um and we both kind of already
there but it wasn't like Gage said
something you could really publicly talk
about because if Gage were to come out
and say you know I'm a firming it would
be difficult for him to find a a
pastoring job at a lot of churches and
so it just kind of felt like something I
had to keep to myself but we got to this
point where it was like this is wrong we
need to do the right thing um and so we
found the table and I cannot put into
words how healing it has been for my
soul like I feel like I'm finally able
to encounter the God that I have known
and searched for my whole life like it
has changed my life and I mean that like
I've never been this excited to go to
church and I've been to church every
Sunday and Wednesday since I was a
newborn um and so um I feel like for me
I've been I've finally been able to to
love and accept people fully the way
that God has always been trying to teach
me and then also on my own journey of
accepting that I am bisexual like like
looking through that lens of of being
able to you know which is also a
difficult thing being already married to
a man again having a a pastor for a
father but he's really kind about it um
but it's just like what do I do with
this and it's been a really healing tool
to be radically accepting here and then
be radically accepting with myself um
and being able to look back on all these
really painful childhood experiences and
and experiences in my adolescence and
understand why I felt that way and I'm
just
I know so much of that of course comes
from therapy shout out therapy um but um
and medication but also like the ability
to really meet God again um has been
something I can't even explain it it is
healed so much within me it's healed my
faith it's healed my belief in God it's
healed my self-image um being able to
fully accept who God made me to
be yeah I think um as we were like in
that I guess early parts of our marriage
and we
were kind of casually attending church
um you know it it
um there were just like subtle things
like you know we I think a lot of people
have experienced this thing where you
know you're at church you're kind of
sitting in the backs you're kind of like
uh I don't know if I'm bought into this
yet and then the pastor says something
and there's just like a like a wincing
that happens or like a oh gosh that's
tough everyone here knows so much from
every Sunday here yeah they're like
amen sorry keep going
um I remember um a pastor of ours who
was like against or I guess
Pro um having like more things in
control for you know preventing anyone
from getting guns and he wouldn't say
anything on Sunday and I think that was
like the first I think that was like the
kick in the pants for me where I was
like all right
think I you know going back to being 15
and the themes of Christianity really
drawing me in it was also the themes
that were actually shown on every Sunday
that Drew me out so it was the themes
that we hear about you know joy and
grace and love but what I was seeing was
the common thing was
like um masking pretending to be
something you're not even for people who
like who you know what they're masking
is like depression or things where you
would hope that a place like the church
would be where they could let that down
um and
so I I think the plan was when we moved
to Garland to go to different churches
like try things out and um you know for
a while now I'd been able to be like
personally affirming like to my friends
and to you know basically like a quiet
supporter and
and I think the fear in me was you know
I think our second or third Sunday here
you said something like you know I don't
think they would have me back and like I
I laughed so I was like the only person
who like was cackling like
I because like I really fully resonate
with the um it's not only that they
wouldn't have me back it's like that um
I I'll be like
blacklisted um and so it was like the
idea that you know what they would say
is open-handed theology right like we
think it's okay to think differently
about these things um and I was always
really confused by like the actual
response if I took that seriously and so
Rachel's first suay here was like she's
skipping in like having like the time of
her life like everything like connects
it's like instant for her where like she
like showed up being like I don't know
if God is real like walks in is like
this is awesome God is real um while I'm
like shaking with anxiety like oh
no um I like have to stand on this now
like I can't casually and you know I
think it took a couple weeks of like the
anxiety like disappearing I think it
really was because like talking to
people and you know like getting more
involved here seing like a lot of the
things that I was hoping for in the
church for my whole life like actually
being real and you know like uh the the
phrase that I'm sure everyone has heard
is like there's no perfect Church um
there's so much hope for me in like the
people in this room of like if something
is messy of it getting figured out and
fixed it's beautifully said um I wanted
to kind of close out with could you
share maybe some encouragement like if
someone is resonating with you know some
aspect of your story and like um
what would you say to them you know I
think for me if you're coming from the
realm of like I'm not even sure if God
is real
um I would encourage you to be
comfortable with those moments um
because For Me growing up in the
environment I grew up in it was all we
were told like it's okay to ask
questions but then also it's like when
you ask questions it has a weight to it
like he was talking about is like I'm
not sure if God is real it's like okay
well you can't serve on this team
anymore I I think I'm affirming well now
you can't work with kids anymore you
know it's it has a weight to it and
learning to be comfortable with I don't
know how I feel about this I have seen
God show up in that I mean even for
example tonight like you know the first
time we came here I whipped because I I
was so like he said I was so excited to
be to I haven't been able to sing you
know because anytime I go home to my
hometown I go to church with my family
um um but I haven't been able to sing in
a worship service um for years because I
don't feel like the people I'm around
really mean it and it makes I'm like I
don't trust this um but here I was
looking around and like we you know like
we are talking about the same God and it
was so exciting to me and then even
tonight like seeing a moment from God
for us like when we got married um the
song that we sang uh was build my life
and I remember singing that as our
worship song on our wedding day when
there was like 10 people there CU we had
a CO wedding um and saying like I want
to build my life on your love that was
what was important to me um is I'm not
worried about the doctrine of it all I
just want to build my life on your love
and to hear that again was like such a
reminder of the goodness of God and the
the kindness of God that like when
you're looking for him he's present and
he's real um and to not be discouraged
if you're not there
yet yeah I think if if if you were like
me and your struggle is with the church
as like a
institution um I would encourage you I
think um a lot of like American white
evangelism has like kind
of changed or at least like informed a
lot of how we View Church as like a
whole um I was really encouraged by the
stories of people who who are not like
me who don't look like me who don't have
the same background as me and to see how
beautiful the church is is to other
people groups
um yeah yeah I think that was the best
thing for
me yeah thank you so much for sharing
can you give them a
[Applause]
hand all right next is Suzanne vote and
Cat Elliott there they are y'all give
them a hand they come
forward
all
right so uh for those who don't know cat
Suzanne and um thank you so much for
sharing and um yeah being with us so
maybe um start off with um just some of
that background you know how were you
raised and was Faith involved if so what
was that like like um yeah give us a a
little background um yeah like like
Brett said I'm Suzanne and this is my
wife cat and we've been married for 28
years just to give a little background
and we have three grown children and one
grandchild and uh we're very proud of
all of them and um it uh for me growing
up I I grew up Catholic but we were the
only go on chur Easter Christmas we
didn't go to church uh it wasn't part of
my family uh so I didn't become involved
in a church until an I was an adult I
was a single mom and um a co-worker a
co- teer said hey bring your kids to
Vacation Bible School at the local
United Methodist Church and I was like
sure okay you know and I got involved
then and uh that that's my that's my
background
that I'm uh I'm a little different I
grew up in in a very conservative
Church um I was there in working in the
church uh all the time as a teenager
especially um got very involved and um
I'm very grateful to the love that I had
growing up and for the knowledge that I
gained of the
Bible and um but I also knew U when I
became a a teen or pre-teen um I
realized my sexual
orientation and I knew that I would not
be accepted in this
church so I left the church for many
many years I left the church before the
church could reject
me and I I was gone away for many many
years so um at some point I know much of
your story kind of centers around church
and um or at least aspects of it and so
I'm wondering what kind of
LED you back and and then tell us a
little bit about there's you know there
was a church that you really poured your
kind of much of your life into um and
there was some Beautiful Moments there
and there was some really heartbreaking
stuff too kind of share a little bit of
that that story okay so when we met um I
was involved in the local United
Methodist Church and and Cat came along
and uh then we moved and we changed jobs
and changed school districts and uh we
ended up in Roy City so
we decided well why don't we just try
the United Methodist Church in Roy City
so we started attending there with at
the time we just had our two children
Sarah wasn't we didn't have her yet so
we went to the church there in Roy
City the first time we walked in the
door um there was a pastor there and she
she saw us and she said oh Lord what
have you brought me
and she she she then took her Bible and
read scriptures and studied and then she
embraced us and she loved
us and she invited us and included us
and we became really
involved um Suzanne actually became the
choir director for a little while an
interim choir
director and um
Jesse I became the skit
lady and you know we we became very
involved and um we had a couple of
really good years and then um as the
United Methodist Church does um they
move pastors quite often and they moved
her and then we got another Pastor who
did not love us who did not Embrace us
or include us and and was very
instrumental and having her fired for
being a choir director um that was the
hurt the the most hurtful thing that
ever happened at this church was her
being fired as being a choir
director
um yes and the church behind closed
doors told and then but they outed us
and we had never came out
I mean it's not that we were ashamed of
it or anything it just wasn't we just
didn't have you know we just figured
people figured it out I guess I don't
know uh we were so involved that um and
accepted that way but um one thing about
the Reverend Betty before is um she
became our spiritual Mentor um and we're
still in touch with her today but so
um I have to have notes because that's
am um so we went ahead and stayed even
though that was very hurtful that was
the most hurtful thing for us we stayed
and we kept working and we kept being
involved and we thought well maybe we'll
make a difference maybe we'll change
some Minds maybe we'll change some
hearts this is the United Methodist
right Open Hearts open minds open doors
uh and they were trying to move to
inclusivity um but
we didn't realize that we were being it
was harmful to our children by staying
and it was harmful to us really as a
whole um then so then you know then we
had that Pastor and then it was a roller
coaster up and down of being accepted
not being accepted and and and having
some good years and not having some good
years and then um and then uh we had a
trauma in our church and they moved to
past Pastor there to help us through
that trauma uh Reverend Anne will it and
she's also one of our spiritual mentors
still and she was there for five years
and a lot of good stuff I mean we really
became involved I really did a lot of
skits I have to keep on with that one I
I I really resonated with that one you
said but um so we had some good years
she baptized our daughter so Sarah and
Sarah
growing up had some good years so we're
very grateful for that
um and then when so good years with with
Reverend Pastor an and then we had a
couple of more good years after they
moved her and then in
2016 they moved a pastor there that was
um very conservative and I could we
could already kind of tell that this
pastor was leading the way
for um this United Methodist to split
into Methodist and let me just explain
something really really quickly
um they did do disaffiliation they did
vote each congregation if they voted to
disaffiliate they dropped United out of
their
name if they if they did not then
they're moving toward inclusivity still
but they're not there yet but they're
moving that way they're wanting that and
they are United Methodist so the
building that we're worshiping in is a
United Methodist and the building that
we're moving to is a United Methodist
that means they're Mo they're trying to
move towards
inclusivity um I just didn't want to
cause any confusion there on
yeah so so we had the very conservative
pastor and the dis affiliation process
happened and it was it was 2019 when it
I had an aha of this is the beginning of
the end I just knew it and then we we
knew Don Jacobs in Royce City he's back
there and he mentioned the table and I
kind of put that just because I I was
gonna we were going to stick it out to
the
end as hard as that was we just wanted
to stick it out to the end so but I knew
about the table in
2019 and then Co and all that happened
so we just worshiped online here and
there we went to a lot of different
denominations online we went to a lot of
United Methodist churches and the we
looked at the table and you know it just
I wasn't didn't connect online was not
there there's no connection there I
already didn't have connection as a
child so I it it was there was no
connection so but the the 2022 Was the
disaffiliation
vote and our Reverend Pastor an
recommended we go and visit the spaces
at the church the day of the vote to
tell to have our closure and say goodbye
and um so sorry so we went to the youth
room first with Sarah and we just sat
there and that was hard it was very
painful because we did a lot of things
with the youth and then we went to our
Sunday school room and lot of good
discussion great that was a great Sunday
school class and we went to the
fellowship hall and that was a lot of
good things there and then when we
walked into the sanctuary for the vote
the most
unpleasant the place where you're
supposed to feel Sanctuary the S it was
horrible I felt horrible and we the vote
happened it was 90 90% to leave and that
was that was the vote was the end
because we heard so many horrible things
about our family during that process
people we'd been worshiping with for 20
plus years it was horrible it was hor
horrible we heard we were being we were
being compared to things that you should
are you shouldn't be compared to and all
we wanted to was just the
worship all all
yeah that um what were some of the so
there you are in that moment and then
you walk away and you know like okay
this is the end for us we're notna be
able to continue There what were the
feelings
um hurt and Ang anger grief and tears
kind of
disbelieving um that this happened we'd
never experienced discrimination in
church and oh we had never I'm sorry we
had never experienced discrimination in
church and um the it was almost like I
felt like there was a waste and I don't
and then I heard the song a while ago
and I just I couldn't even sing it where
it says nothing is wasted and I thought
thought that those 20 years were could
not have been wasted but I felt like
they were wasted just a wasted time
waste of they took our children our
tithe our time our heart our whatever
and they used it and and I know we're
don't go to church for the people but
when that we go to church for God I know
that but that's not that's but yeah we
walked away we walked away from that
yeah so um you decide to leave
and I know this is all still pretty you
know fresh and raw I mean we're just the
beginning of 2024 and you're talking you
know kind of latest 2022 so it's not
like you know 10 years ago we went
through this and now this is still
pretty rough so what are the how are you
doing now you know like what's what's
the obviously you're here at the table
um again without feeling need to put a
bow on it have there been kind of
moments of Grace um what what have been
some of those those kinds of moments as
you've you know continued the journey
well first of all since we came here
since we came here we've we've been here
um every week you know
um it's been wonderful the people the
the affirming um the love you can just
feel the
love
um one of yeah go ahead I'm just going
to say one uh we we found out later too
that some of the youth our church that
we were attending in Roy City knew that
they were okay to be lgbtq because we
kept going so that was another that was
a a that was a a hopeful thing to find
out nothing's been wasted that it hasn't
been wasted even though I felt that yes
and and then in I guess in September of
this past year cat said oh I saw a post
that Sally Gary is going to be speaking
at the table you tell her story about
being Christian and in the lgbtq
community and she said let's go and I
was like okay really I didn't mean I
don't mean to that but I was like okay
sure let's go and we've been every
Sunday since except for a couple that
we've missed and so we've enjoyed the it
it I'm I'm not healed but I'm in the
it's I feel the process I feel it
yeah um did you have anything else I
don't think I didn't I don't think so
okay then um kind of what encouragement
you know for there's obviously I'm sure
folks connecting with your story and the
feeling of investing so much in a
community only for it to at least feel
wasted um what what input perspective
would you or encouragement would you
offer them U first of all something that
came to my mind in the night last night
because I I couldn't sleep was you can't
it's not something you're just going to
get over because I we've had family or
people say oh you you get you'll get
over it you're not going to just get
over it you don't just get over it it
takes a lot of time and even between cat
and I her time is different than my time
and we're we're realizing that she's
might be ready to do something and I'm
not so the time and just
um yeah each each of us each of us has
their has our own time there was one
more thing I was going to say oh and
that questions please ask questions
questions are okay because I never I
grew up thinking questions were not okay
not just because I did I didn't grow up
in church but in my family questions
were not okay so the questions are
okay I would just say pray and and
continue to study the word his word um
surround yourself with positive people
and with discussion groups or support
groups or whatever you need to be able
to get things
out um just and just um
yeah and that's the discussion groups is
how we met and got to know Don J Don Don
Jacobs a little better was we started a
discussion group in Roy City and he
joined so that's that's where this
started yeah you never know how God will
bring people into that you need into
your life um through those kinds of
connections and yeah that's it's
beautiful thank you so much for sharing
your story can you all give them a
hand
than oh so good every year just fills my
heart like yeah and thank you um Gage
and Rachel thank you suzan and Cat Just
for sharing you can you can imagine it
takes a lot of courage to get up here
and and share I I intentionally ask them
to share you know a few levels deeper
than maybe you might normally hear and
um and they've done that and it's it's
really powerful and um man what a work
God's doing in in them and uh yeah and I
hope you did see the connections you
know those little moments that where it
intersects with your story or feelings
that they named that you have felt um
man take some time to reflect on that
and let God um speak to you uh in those
ways and places so um we are going to
take communion now and uh as we come to
the table of the Lord you know each of
us brings our own
stories and uh maybe you're here tonight
and you're in like a hallelujah praise
the Lord kind of Mountaintop moment uh
maybe you are in like the lowest of lows
you resonated with all the low moments
in their stories you know and uh or
maybe somewhere in between um no matter
where you are just know that Christ is
here and present and seeks to meet with
you uh so so a few things to to know we
the way we'll do this we'll just go kind
of row by row here from the front and
move backwards that way we don't get
like a crazy long line um if you are
here tonight and like something in you
wants to participate we practice what's
called an open table so you are welcome
to participate regardless of
denomination or theology or background
or whatever um if you want to connect
with the Risen Christ then you you are
um welcome to do that you should know
the red is wine and the white is grape
juice
um and uh all right I think that's
everything so this is the table not of
the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
chist himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
I doubt it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're an artist in a
Potter I'm the canvas the clay I know
nothing
has been wasted no failure or mistake
you're an artist and
a stand and sing that with
us
all
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work together
For Your
Glory and for your name you're not
finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me yet you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
you're not
fin there we go that's test uh Rachel
Gage Suzanne cat thank you so much for
sharing your story and feeling feeling
comfortable knowing that um you are
accepted here just the way you are and
that goes for everyone and as uh Suzanne
and Cat mentioned you know we can't
forget whether you are gay whether you
are an ally we cannot forget things that
have happened and those have caused
scars but stand firm and knowing that
with every scar comes a story and with
every story comes the idea and the
actions of Triumph resilience bravery
and courage and you are loved here scars
and all yeah um just a couple of
reminders uh I want to thank you you all
for joining us this evening um if you
are new of course we definitely want to
thank you for being here um please scan
either this code or fill out one of the
page the little forms in the foyer just
for us to get to know you just for us to
welcome you um yeah just to get get to
know you a little bit and let you know
you know what we're about and how we can
support you if you're in need of a
prayer a hug a high five or anything
come find me after service go find Brett
really anyone that's up on stage AG we'd
H we'd be happy to be there for you in
any way that we can here at the table we
are committed to creating an inclusive
Christ centered community in place where
we can all worship together and touch
hearts of those here and those around us
and in order to do so um generosity on
our part as members is a key component
to that so if you feel led to give again
you can scan that QR code or you can
fill out one of those little papers in
the on the table in the for you to do
so um so I'm going to send us out with
the benediction I always say it's near
and dear to my heart uh you can stand in
a posture of receiving eyes closed you
can you know whatever you're comfortable
with you are a child of God you are a
child of God this is true on your best
day and this is especially true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just the way that you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact with
hope to see you at hat Creek and if not
be blessed we'll see you next week thank
you
all when I doubt it Lord remind me I'm
one Wonder ful made you're an artist and
a the the I know nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistakes you're an arst
and a I'm
the the you make all
things work
together for my
future
and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name and you're not
finished with me you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me yet you're
not fin with me you're not finished with
me yet you're not finished with me
you're not
[Music]
finished